royal couple Prince Harry and Meghan
Markle are celebrating their newest
family member our Lauren zema has all
the furry details yes I am here outside
the Beagle Freedom project with a couple
cuties and the Royals adopted this cutie
seven-year-old Mamma Mia just two weeks
ago it all started when Duchess Megan
herself called this woman right here
I heard is it true that at first you
thought it was actress Megan Fox calling
you well I was guessing because she was
like Hey Shannon it's Megan and I'm like
hey I was like Megan who she and Prince
Harry came over here to meet Mia she ran
right to them and it's like she knew
these are my people Shannon Keith runs
the non-profit that rescued Mia from a
breeding facility for medical research
they really wanted to adopt a dog who
has had a traumatized past that they
support our mission of ending animal
testing
the Duke and Duchess are already doggy
parents to another rescue Beagle named
guy and a lab named Pula and we know
pups love Megan including the Queen's
corgis according to 13 straight away
33 years
just laying on my feet during tea it was
very sweet Archie and Lil Yvette how do
you think she will like life with them
Mamma Mia will love it because she's a
mother herself right and so she's gonna
love to be a mom to them I know it
thank you
foreign